[Music]
it's a program that I'm involved with at
the University of Florida right now
Florida the percentage of kids reading
at grade level is 43 percent the best in
the country is Massachusetts at 62
percent so nobody should be standing up
and going look at our state where 62
percent so it's not good anywhere
University of Florida has been working
at a program for five years up in the
Gainesville area not Gainesville itself
because there are too many professors
kids in the town but outside and they
have it up into the 80s so I've been
working with them and we went to the
state legislature in April and when you
met with the head of the Senate and and
several senators and the in the house
and they gave us two counties in Florida
and they said if you can get you know to
get ATS but if you get good numbers you
get numbers in the sixties we will take
that program across the state which
would be spectacular it's a win-win-win
for the kids it's a win for the teachers
it's a win for the state everybody
everybody wins and you know when I go
and I talk to when I will when I talk to
the to the legislature and and when I go
in and talk to big groups of librarians
or teachers I'll always say I'm here to
save lives and I really want people to
get that in their heads because that's
what's happening I go to sometimes now
to to prisons and you know primarily
what you'll find there are a lot of
relatively young African American kids
and most of whom didn't read it all in
high school or almost none weren't good
readers now they read like crazy because
it's the only thing they can do and the
irony is incredible most of a pretty
good readers now had they learned had we
you know got that percentage of kids
reading at grade level up higher to the
point where when they got to high school
they were competent readers they might
have stayed with it but if you get to
high school you get to you know ninth
grade and you really like Abraham you
know you can't you can't keep up you go
I can't do this it's not relevant I
can't do it so I'm not gonna I'm not
going to stay here I'm not gonna stay in
school it's just a disaster and that's
what I I really mean it when I
say you know that that we can save lives
and thousands of lives if we do this
thing in Florida we will save thousands
of lives in Florida and any state that
can solve the problem is going to save
thousands of lives and plus you can
improve the the economics of the state
there's you're gonna have that many more
people who can go out into the workforce
that have choices you know that's
important it's usually important things
and I think it's a it's kind of a sacred
mission I have a an imprint at little
brown called Jimmy books and our mission
which is I think kind of simple but I
think it's smart is when a kid finishes
a Jimmy book they'll say please give me
another book as opposed to I hate books
and I'd like to read because there are
millions of kids running around this
country right now they do not like to
read they don't they're there they've
been introduced to it incorrectly if we
you know if we taught film into little
kids and we started with Ingmar Bergman
movies
that'll go I don't really like movies
you know so and unfortunately that's
what we do with kids in a lot of English
classes let's go through with the are a
million rules that you need to learn and
that's not the most interesting thing
and then we're gonna you know make you
read a lot of stuff that it isn't really
relevant to you yet or you're not really
that interested and then you wonder why
kids are going I don't like to read
because you're introducing it to them
badly so I want to try to make sure that
that what we do that they're gonna love
the stories and at the end of it they're
gonna say give me another book not not
not junk not you know not like you know
stuff right so something you know like
the kind of food you can't remember
whether you ate or not I want to
remember that they did that they read a
book but but that they want another book
yeah I mean it's a tricky dangerous time
for but you know we need a literature I
mean we don't need James Patterson but
we do need Hemingway and Faulkner and
you know the country into literature and
for that to happen for the moment at
least we need traditional publishers
because that's where that happens that's
where we have the experience in the
editors and the time and they're willing
to not
take enormous profits in order to bring
some of those books to people there may
come a time when that can be done on the
Internet and that's okay
but not right now you know right now if
you know if you're lyses came out and it
went on the internet and it would get
three negative reviews and then it would
disappear you know so so we can't have
that happening and because the internet
they're just not ready for it they don't
have the editors they don't you know so
it really is important that we keep
publishers healthy for the moment it's
really important that we have bookstores
for the moment independents are you know
coming back a bit which is which is good
they're more independents this year than
there were last year that's a good thing
it's not a good thing that borders went
out of business because we just need
what we need more bookstores we just do
we need we need people you need people
in the stores where you know people come
up and go what's good or what do you
think of this one or I like this in this
what else might I like or in particular
with kids it's particularly important
because the parents are come and they
don't really know you know all some do
but a lot of parents don't know they
don't know where to start so it's good
if they can have somebody to talk to one
of the problems with with a lot of you
know parents going online is that their
kids aren't kids are not going online
with books they're not reading them for
the most part reading on Kindles and
nooks so you if you have a family where
the parents have gone online and they're
not going into spook stories anymore
then they're not buying books for the
kids and the kids are not reading online
so we have X number of families where
the kids just have no place to go for
books so that's not a good thing
that's I mean to me that's the you just
are the biggest problem we have which is
making sure that our kids are readers
the biggest insight and and and thing
that can be done is is this and and this
was it's complicated in terms of all the
things in the pro
in Florida but but but but the big thing
is in schools from from preschool up
through fourth grade pretty much every
teacher teaches reading but a lot of
them have not learned how to teach
reading some have but a lot of them have
it so the key is teaching them and and
and they can do it under computers they
can do it on their phones teaching them
how to be better teeth better it had a
how to teach reading better a lot of
schools might have a reading teacher
there and that teacher will help the
teachers to be better ways to teach
reading but it's not enough it's not
nearly enough and we can ruin and what
the University of Florida's fund is they
have ways to really help almost all any
teacher who wants to get better at it
and I went to it to a meeting about 800
teachers and this had to do with one of
these counties and getting them up to up
to snuff and the first when they arrived
there they were all a little skeptical
but then after a day or day and a half
they went this really is helpful and
when I said to him I said this is not
about gotcha we're not here to make you
look silly we're not here to criticize
we're not here to test you this is about
help you this is about help you be even
better than you are as a teacher help
your kids to learn even better you know
because obviously 43% is not working the
way you want it to work or you know
Massachusetts 62 percent that's not
that's not great it's not good I don't
know what it is in you know New York New
York is below 63 362 percent though
[Music]
you